[Music]
if someone has made the leap from
i don't want to feel that too
maybe i should feel that i wonder what
it would be like to feel these things
any other suggestions so another one is
captions and i'll tell you what i mean
by that
there was this viral video and it was
put out by the cleveland clinic hospital
and um and it was originally meant to
just be
a video for its caregivers to teach
empathy
but it ended up going viral and
and the way this video worked
it basically took you on a visual tour
down the hospital corridors so you're
just passing
all these humans
and these are people who you would
normally just walk past in the corridor
without really thinking that much
but in this case the video had captions
underneath each one telling you what
they were experiencing at that moment
and in some cases they were experiencing
something joyful like
just found out he's going to be a father
i think is one of them
but because it's a hospital more often
the captions are things like
a little girl visiting her father for
the last time or you know just found out
that the tumor is malignant or whatever
it is and maybe we can link to this also
in your show notes oh for sure
we'll find it yeah i mean you can't you
can't watch this video without
tearing up but it's but it's more than
the tearing up
you can't watch it without having that
physical sensation of your heart opening
up it's like it's just opening and the
lesson for me of that video and i try to
do it now
when i just walk around
is think well what are people's captions
you know just random passersby like the
you know the person who's checking out
your groceries what are her captions
and it's just an
incredible way of kind of
letting
[Music]
sorrows in you know and normalizing them
yeah
which also reminds me like another
concrete thing i think people could do
in the workplace
so we know one of the studies i talk
about in my book
was done by two people named jason
kanoff and laura madden and they looked
at people's description of their work
lives and what they found is people
would describe to them
all these you know terrible things that
had happened to them at work
and the stories revealed how terrible
they were but when they described their
emotions
instead of saying they had felt anxious
they would say they were angry
and instead of saying they had felt sad
they would say they were frustrated
and we need a way of opening up this
language because
i noticed this the other day i did a
talk about introversion in this case
it was like a zoom call
for a company and at the beginning of
the zoom call it started out the way it
often does with like a nice chat
and and somebody asked the question like
how's everybody feeling this morning you
know and and all the answers were like
pumped you know yay i'm feeling great
i'm energized happy
and
and these are all amazing emotions i'm
not trying to take away from them
it's just you have to ask what are the
chances that every human
responding
in that chat box was truly feeling
only those emotions what are the chances
of that yeah they're actually incredibly
low
i believe there are ways for
workplaces to
normalize the expression of all of the
different emotions that we have
you know even by something as simple as
in in a physical workplace where people
are really showing up you know having
like a board up on the wall where people
can just write down that morning what
are you actually feeling what are you
actually going through
like in schools they call that a parking
lot and i think we need a parking lot
in workplaces too
i didn't realize i didn't have one of
those growing up yeah exactly so there
are schools where they actually have a
blackboard or whiteboard where kids
write down how they're feeling
yep
you